thank you again to nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video
a big part about taking care of myself
is letting myself potato
and frankly sometimes i just sit on my
phone like everybody else
and so while my social media habits are
something that i'm still working on
one thing that i definitely don't
compromise is my internet safety
nordvpn is a vpn service that i use on
my phone
and my laptop it's really important to
protect your data while in public
so nordvpn has double data encryption
for increased anonymity
and they don't do any data logging you
can have up to six simultaneous
connections and yes you can unlock
netflix
and your favorite entertainment websites
they've also got amazing customer
service policies like a 30-day
money-back guarantee
and 24 7 customer support so make sure
to go to
nordvpn.com myuco
or use code myuco to get a two-year plan
plus one additional month with a huge
discount
hey everybody how's it going my name's
miyuko and welcome back to my channel so
i think one of the best parts about
getting older is that you get to know
yourself better
and one of the things that i've realized
about myself recently
was that march is always rough for me
and i realized that it's because all the
stuff that i committed to at the
beginning of the year in january or at
the end of the year last year
that i committed to because i was just
like what am i going to do with my life
and my year i feel like march is when
all of that kind of just hits the fan
and so truly what's required of me
during this time is like
patience perseverance and determination
to get all that stuff done and then it's
also subsequently
when i usually get burnt out because i'm
just like stressed for long periods of
time
and usually it does end in burnout to be
honest
but then this year now that i realize
that it's like a pattern
i'm kind of realizing that like oh you
know this is nothing new this is
actually totally cyclical
i'm right where i'm supposed to be and
so i'm actually i think more aware of
that which means that i'm taking
better care of myself this year and when
i say that i realized that it's been a
pattern
i mean it's been a pattern since like as
far as i can trace like 2014
maybe even before that to like basically
all of my 20s
don't get me wrong like all the things
that i've committed to are things that
i'm really
lucky to be able to do and have the
opportunity of doing
and they're all things that i genuinely
feel excited to do and i'm happy to do
but guess what your girl's human and so
i get tired and stressed in doing this
work which is like
totally normal and so since my
realization a few weeks ago
i've been kind of changing my gears and
really taking care of myself to move
through this so today i'm going to share
with you
how i take care of myself when i'm
stressed
obviously this looks different for
everybody but i wanted to give you
an invitation into my world as i work
through
yet another march so the first thing
that i do is to figure out
why i'm stressed because figuring out
that source is important to me
because if i can introspect it and
pinpoint it
then i have a lot more clarity on what i
actually need
to get through that stress and so
needless to say
this is like my number one priority in
taking care of myself when i'm stressed
i think about it during my walk so when
i'm just like staring out the window
during work
or sometimes when i'm feeling like
really particularly anxious and i need
answers as to why and then i also make
sure not to ruminate on it for too long
because i find that that it's
counterproductive because then i'm
stressed out
about the fact that i'm stressed out so
the next thing that i do once i figure
out
what i'm stressed out about is to
basically forgive myself for it
and for all the feelings that come with
it and that's because i feel like i used
to judge myself
and beat myself up about it because i
felt like i shouldn't be stressed but
then i realized
that you kind of owe it to yourself to
show some self-compassion and to not
judge yourself and not be such a harsh
critic
about your current feelings and your
current state because like that's not
how you would treat a friend that you
really love right
so i don't know i realized that it's
just why
be my worst enemy when i could be my own
biggest fan
because feelings and stuff if i ignore
something
and i push it down deep inside of me
then it'll usually come back
in a much bigger form anyways so
especially for something like stress
i realize it's really important for me
to see it
to truly accept it understand it and
then move from there
and my therapist always says that being
able to identify it and then understand
it is always the first step so i try to
do this
first and foremost so once i figure out
what i'm stressed about then it's really
just asking myself the question what do
i
need right now and it honestly looks
really different depending on
many many factors like depending on the
time of the day
depending on the hour depending on what
exactly i'm stressed about
i'm gonna need something different and i
like to think of it as kind of like a
plant
where plants at different points in
their life stage and condition
need something different this analogy
also makes me realize how much of like a
living
breathing being i am and so sometimes
all i need
is rest i find that when i'm like
stressed out i actually end up
relying on adrenaline to get me through
the day and while that's helpful
it's just not sustainable in the long
run to me it feels exactly like
when you realize that you're eating so
fast only when you
stop eating and you're just like why am
i eating so fast
so yeah rest in the form of afternoon
naps
getting eight to ten hours of sleep at
night sometimes just like
lying down horizontally on my couch and
not thinking about anything
and then also sometimes it's literally
just remembering to breathe
other times what i need is food i'm like
really food motivated so like nine times
out of ten
if i eat like a good nutritious meal
then not only will it help feed like my
body and my physical state but also like
my soul
and the other thing that i try to
remember is that even though sometimes
when i'm stressed i'm like i don't want
to talk to anybody because i'm too busy
sometimes what i really need is social
interaction so i'll call up a friend
just a chat or i call my brother
and tell him why i'm so stressed because
sometimes it just helps to like get that
out into words
and like rant honestly sometimes just
like hanging out with my dogs will do
the trick
too because who doesn't want to hang out
with dogs like they're soft and cuddly
and so nice and then other times i'll
just sit
with scott and talk about life or career
or the future or whatever and then
especially during the pandemic i find
that social interaction has really
helped me to de-stress
like i think of it as kind of like a
form of ikinki which
hard thing to translate but i'll leave
the definition right here and
lastly the way that i take care of
myself when i'm stressed is to just give
myself some joyful moments
so that's things like going on long
walks or listening
and dancing around to good music or
sometimes it's just like a nice little
oyatsu with like a cup of tea
i often need to remind myself that it's
okay to rest and take breaks
and also enjoy life even if i'm like
really stressed out about all the work
that i have to do
or everything that's going on in the
world like it's okay to enjoy
because you know what life always goes
long and uh
you might as well enjoy it while you can
so that's it that's how i take care of
myself when i'm stressed out
honestly it's a lot about like getting
my body and soul nourished because
oftentimes what stresses me out is
everything that's going on like mentally
or like within my brain
again depending on the day the hour
whatever
like my needs will change but i think as
i've gotten older i've gotten really
good at listening to
my body and soul for what it truly needs
at that time i think that's like one of
the perks of getting older to be honest
like i
i quite like it being stressed is never
fun but frankly like it's
never gonna go away and i think it's
similar to anxiety where
like anxiety is never gonna go away so a
lot of it is just about getting good at
living
with anxiety and with stress and moving
through it gracefully
so i hope this helped you in some way
thank you all so much for watching if
you haven't done so already
then make sure to subscribe and if you'd
like to support this channel then make
sure to join my membership program
through youtube by clicking the join
button down below where you get
exclusive access to live stream
recordings as well as emojis
i'll see you next time and take care
everybody bye